would you ever run for president again
no no but I'm gonna do everything I can
to make sure that we have a president
who respects our democracy and the rule
of law and upholds our institutions what
if Donald Trump runs again he should be
soundly defeated it should start in the
Republican Party grow a backbone stand
up to this guy and heaven forbid if he
gets the nomination he needs to be
defeated roundly and sent back to
Mar-A-Lago the Florida mansion now in
the spotlight after an FBI so she's
being very clear here she's not running
for president again now those who are
committed to the idea of some conspiracy
to install Hillary Clinton or whatever
they will say that she still might run
but I believe her it seems very clear
that she isn't running and I think that
this is correct I don't think that she
should run again she would have been a
better president than Trump I voted for
her but I believe that the window has
passed and I think it's the same thing
with Bernie Sanders quite frankly